three cruise ships with Iran twelve
thousand tourists on board were anchored
in the harbor as the North African
refugee swamp for their lives six men
drowned less than 40 meters from catania
Beach a gruesome scene at one of Italy's
most popular holiday spots a beach bar
owner saw the men struggling and called
the authorities clementoni of the
opposite asleep when I saw the boat
persona con man I thought it was part of
an effort to rescue the people in the
water they Gnostic rd I can't believe
it's the vessel they came here on
persona que vino Inferno Libya my Utah
to Punta gosta the coast guards told the
bolt in after the drownings officials
believe around 100 people risked the
journey across the Mediterranean the
board hit a sandbank just a few meters
from land fearing capture the refugees
scrambled to reach the shore whistle
doubled Raja go the lava it's a tragic
turn of events the drowning victims are
all men five adults and one boy aged 15
or 16 Windy City sharni survivors say
they are from syria and egypt every year
tens of thousands attempt the crossing
from north africa authorities say a long
stretch of good weather has increased
the number this summer
well meanwhile police in France and
Spain have arrested 75 people suspected
of helping Chinese immigrants illegally
relocate to Europe and the United States
Chinese citizens desperate